cette guerre ans en ukraine fuir tant
qu'il est encore temps ce sont donc des
dizaines de milliers de civils qui ont
repris ce matin la route les autorités
ukrainiennes annonce la reprise des
évacuations dans les villes dire pin est
soumis soumis on vous le rappelle
lourdement frappé l'année dernière par
l'aviation russe où l'on déplore depuis
au moins neuf morts dont deux enfants
les autorités russes avaient annoncé un
peu plus tôt l'ouverture de corridors
humanitaires dans cinq localités du pays
marina bergeron jour en écrite ensemble
ces annonces on l'a vu ces dernières
jours il a eu cette offre russe nous
verture de corridors humanitaires qui
ont toutes échoué jusqu'ici mais il
semblerait ce matin que cela fonctionne
en tout cas en partie pour une seule
ville dans le nord est du pays vous en
parliez la ville de soumis c'est
effectivement confirmé des civils sont
bien en cours d'évacuation soumis c'est
une ville qui se trouve à 50 km de la
frontière russe la voilà cette ville
vous en avez parlé elle a été lourdement
bombardée encore cette nuit avec ce tout
dernier bilan qui vient de nous parvenir
21 morts dans cette ville de soumis
bombardement d'une zone résidentielle
très tôt ce matin alors le chemin de
soumis apparemment le voilà il va vers
le sud ces bus se dirigeraient à 175 km
au sud dans cette région ici dans une
ville qui s'appelle poltava donc à 175
km au sud de soumis on a vu un donc ces
images d'habitants en train de monter
dans des bus des habitants mais pas
seulement il est aussi des étudiants
étrangers qui communique beaucoup sur
twitter des étudiants africains
notamment donc on a bien un cessez le
feu qui devrait durer en heure locale de
9h à 21h à suivre vous en parliez des
d'autres éventuels corridor qui
pourraient être ouverts les villes de
karkhiv czerny give marioupol mais pour
l'instant rien n'est sûr et rien n'est
confirmé
ce que je peux vous dire ce matin c'est
que des habitants sont en train de
quitter la ville de soumis et ce tout
dernier chiffre qui nous est parvenu
deux millions de personnes sont en train
de fuir l'ukraine voilà du nouveau du
terrain des nouvelles de mario paul
notamment l'une des cinq villes évoquées
par par moscou on vous le savez les
rudes communique depuis tôt ce matin sur
ses couloir humanitaire ouvert selon eux
1 notamment à marioupol il semblerait
que le vice premier ministre ukrainien
fasse état de 30 bus en route justement
vers marioupol pour recueillir récupérer
ces réfugiés on verra évidemment ce
qu'il est ce qu'il en advient dans les
heures qui arrivent plus globalement
marina qu'en est-il de l'avancée des
forces heureuse je le disais tout à
l'heure l'étau qui se resserre autour
des grandes villes notamment saas
poursuit oui on va regarder ensemble la
carte qu'on peut dire globalement ce
matin c'est que il n'y a pas d'avancée
notable des troupes russes sur le
terrain et qui continue donc des lourds
bombardements sur les principales villes
y compris dans des halls 1 on l'a dit où
se trouvent des civils ce qu'on peut
dire ce matin c'est que les attaques
s'intensifient et que le bilan humain
s'alourdit on parlait à l'instant de la
ville de soumis mais également à karl
yves la deuxième ville du pays les
habitants on a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux qui étaient appelés à descendre
dans le métro à kharkiv pour y trouver
eau et nourriture on a aussi évidemment
va y revenir plus en détail ensemble la
capitale kiev nicolas yves dans le sud
est évidemment marioupol ce qui se passe
c'est que de nombreuses villes
ukrainiennes sont en état de siège
d'ailleurs les ukrainiens accusent
l'armée russe de tactique de siège
médiéval ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
plus d'eau plus de nourriture plus de
chauffage tout ça se fait très rare en
ukraine et puis cette information qu'on
a eu également dans la nuit une lourde
perte pour les russes un commandant
russe de haut rang vitaly est guère
asimov chef d'état-major premier
commandant adjoint de la 41e armée qui
est tombé près de kharkiv donc
globalement ce qu'on peut dire elisabeth
ce matin c'est que la progression russe
et a ralenti au sol d'où les
bombardements intenses mais on attend
évidemment une contre offensive russe
merci beaucoup marina marina berges
champ pour
c'est ces précisions vous nous faites
signe évidemment si vous avez si vous
avez d'une